[音楽]
voodoo
[拍手]
[音楽]
僕はバスケットボールの家庭教師という事業をやっています
まあのチームスポーツのように家庭教師ってこう思った人も青いかもしれません
実際に
家庭教師的に個人のほどもにバスケを教えにします
でもちろんチームに呼ばれていくこともあります
でもこの授業は単に子供たちにバスケをしているってだけじゃなくて指導者を育て
るって言うことも大事なテーマなんです
子供たちに教えるということと指導者を育てるということ
この2つの活動を行っているのがこの僕の事業のポイントなんです
今日は
僕がこの事業を立ち上げる中で学んだことをお話ししようと思います
ところで
あのことわざでありますけど
ことわざに守備範囲があるって皆さん考えたことありますかね
あの後はザって万能じゃない
いつどんな時でもそれが有効なんじゃなくてある限られた条件の時だけその教訓が有効
だったりします
その代表的なことわざなぁ二刀追うものは一刀も得ずです
このことわざは2つのものを手に入れようとしたら
両方手に入らないまつまりにタークに迫られたら
欲張ってどっちも取ろうとしないでどちらか一方に集中しなさいっていうそういう意味
です
まあ確かに目の前にうさぎや2匹いて左右別々の方向に逃げ打者としたらその瞬間に
この2匹を捕まえようとするともうどちらも逃してしまう
そういうことわざです
でもここで思い出してほしいのが先ほどの大臣の守備範囲です
このことわざの守備範囲は
今その瞬間にウサギを捕まえなければならないという時間的な条件です
もしも司会のずっと先にもう息をサギ見えてて
これからはなとか餌とかを用意する
時間的な余裕があるとします
だとしたら
2匹を捕まえるつもりで準備をした人しか
2色を捕まえることはできないです
多くの人がこの時間的な守備範囲を考えないで
このことわざの教訓を理解しています
だから二択に迫られた時にどちらか一方にもう縛らなきゃって
どちらか一方に決めなきゃって考えちゃうんです
a と b のも飲みたく
どちらにも良い点があって
あひラベルには惜しい選択肢でももうに通ったら
どっちも手に入らない泣く泣くどちらか一方を選んでしまう
でもそこで考える必要があるのです
その
洗濯は本当に正しかったのかっていう
それは a と b の正しい方を選んだのかということじゃなくて
その a と b は本当に二択だったのかっていうことです
仁藤うつもりで考え尽くせば伊藤を得られるアイディアが
見つかるんじゃないでしょうか
僕たちが普段であっているみたくの中には実は両方取れる
第さあが隠れているのではないでしょうか
僕はこのことを自分の事業立ち上げの経験から学びました
僕は職4年生の時にバスケの強豪中学がある学区に転向者です
もうその当時は漫画のスラムダンク
nba はマイケルジョーダンバス系人気がもう絶頂期で僕は日に日にバスケに夢中に
なっていきました
だけど早い段階で僕はプレイヤーとしては二階レベルにいくのは無理だなって思って
ました
あの残念ながら身体的にも技術的にも全国レベルの先輩たちのようになるのはちょっと
難しいなって考えたんです
でも当時から僕は人に教えるということがすごく好きでした
後輩たちに負け教えて
その子たちが嬉しそうにしてるのを見るととても充実感を感じてたのを覚えています
そんなこともあって当時の僕は将来中学校の先生になろうって思っていました
ただ僕は当時からちょっと野心家なところがあって
他の人が真似できないようなことを達成したいっていうそういう思いがあったので
中学校の先生になったらその学校を全国大会で優勝させたい
まあそういう指導者になりたいって考えてたんですこれが僕が最初に考えた
将来の夢
それで教員免許を取るために僕は大学に進学します
でもそこであのある指導者との運命的な出会いをするんです
日高2郎先生との出会いです
もう日高先生のコーチングはまるで魔法でした
先生の言うとおりにシュートを打つとなぜかシュートがよく入ったし技術的な壁に
ぶつかっても的確なアドバイスで成長を後押ししてくださいました
元の日高先生との出会いで僕は先生のようなコーチングをもっと多くの子どもたちに
届けられたらいいんじゃないかなって考えるようになったんです
そうして
僕の将来の夢は変わっていきました
最初は
一つのチームを教えてそのチームを強くしていくっていう一流をイメージしたんです
けど
一つのチームとにこだわらないでもっと多くの子どもたちに貢献するって言うその貢献
を大きくしていくような一流もあるんじゃないかなって考えるようになったんです
そこで僕は
将来指導者になるような
学生たちを育てるために大学の先生になろうって考えたんです
もだよ先生になって
視聴者育てていってその育て先でどんどん貢献を大きくしていく
そんなことを考えたわけですこれが僕の将来のよねぇ
b 案です
みなさんこれもうお分かりですかね僕にとってこれが無意識の二択になってたってこと
です
もともとは子どもに教えるのが好きで選んでた
もう中学の先生になるという選択肢を捨てて
指導者になるという選択肢を選んだんです
この子どもに教えるということと指導者になる
学生たちに指導法を教えるというのは全く違う仕事です
当時の僕はどちらか一方を選んだらもう一方は選ぶことができないっていうそういう
発想に縛られていました
でもここから僕の人生は急転します
大学院に進んで
勉強の家庭教師のアルバイトをしようと思いました
そこで依頼を受け付けるためのホームページを作り始めたんです
で作ってる途中で
バスケットの指導者になりたいんだからバスケットボールの家庭教師ってしてみたら
面白いんじゃないかって思って
それホームページの内容をバケツバスケ東の端提供 c にも交えて
で勉強の家庭教師みたいに家庭から依頼を受けたらバスケ教えに行くっていうそういう
授業を始めたわけです
でも当時は
子どもたちがバスケットボールをすると言ったら
どっかのチームに所属して
そのチームでしかバスケはも教わることができないというのは常識だった
そういうあの時代でした
でも
少しずつこの地域によっては指導者不足が言われ始めしたりとか
バスケ部がないっていう学校がちょっと増えつつあったりとか
の僕の授業の開始は社会のニーズとぞマッチしたんだと思います
しばらくすると依頼が増えていきました
そこで僕は
この事業後輩たちにも手伝ってもらおうと思ったんです
ただ
手伝ってもらうにしてもお金をいただいてコーチングをするわけだから
そのしっかりと勉強してしっかりと準備をして指導に太ってことを後輩たちに言って
いきました
それで公害等のための指導の勉強会も始めました
僕はそこで気付いたんです
この事業は
もともとやりたかった
子供たちに教えるという a 案と
この指導者を育てるというビアンの両方を取れる事業だったんです
それまで僕は
永安か p 安価っていう2択の分岐点に立った化されてて
ba の夢の方にシフトしてました
でもこの a か b かって二択には当時の僕には気付けなかった
もう築こうともしれなかった両方を取れるっていう
第さあがあったんです
僕はこの経験等 e 2択に迫られたら
しかもその二択がどちらも捨て方へ3択だったらその両方を取れる第三を探すように
なりました
例えば
僕の仕事の指導者という面では
その教えるということと選手に考えさせるって事は常に難しい一択なんです
小中学生の指導者として
もうきちんと教えるって言うこともあえて教えすぎずに選手に考えさせるってことも
どちらも大事な要素なんです
で多くの場合指導者はどちらかのスタイルに偏りがちになります
でも僕はこの2つを同時に扱える
コーチングスタイルを目指しました
この両方を取るコーチングスタイルを追求し続けたことによって
まあ僕は指導者として沢山のチャンスを掴んでくれたんじゃないかなって思ってます
さあここでちょっと思い出してみてください
これまでいくつの二択に行ってきましたか
その二択は
どちらも捨てがたいもので
でも仕方なくどちらか一方選んだという経験はないですか
例えば
学生時代だったら
部活か勉強カーとか
仕事の時では
好きなことを仕事にするかこと安定を重視した仕事にするか
家庭を持ったら仕事か家庭かん
まあこういった僕たちに引きつけられている
二択の中には実は両方を取れる
第三が見つかるものもあるんです
今日
僕が
伝えたい相手やっていうのは
両方とも捨てがたい似た国であったらその両方を取れる
第三を見つけようっていうことです
ただ皆さんここでちょっと問題があるんです
このアイディア
たとえばさっきほど僕が話しした好きなことを仕事にするって
あれ好きなことそのまま仕事にできたら最高だなって思った人って結構たくさんいると
思うんですよ
つまり a も b も両方取れたらいいなって思っては居るって事です
でも
ほとんどの人がそれを選ばない
やっぱり心のどっかで二兎は追えないって考えてしまう
a も b も取れるに抱くを
その例を看取る選択を
その実際に実践するって
実践できるっていう人は本当に少ない
そうこのアイディア第3案を見つけるってアイディアの問題は実践するのが難しいって
いうところなんです
じゃあなんで難しいんでしょうか
委託に迫られた人が
2頭をいる可能性を模索するためには何が必要なんでしょうか
僕がポイントが3つあると思います
1つは時間の意識です
人生は
時間で出来ています
a か b かって梨沢に出会ったときにそこでの洗濯がその後の人生の時間の中身を
決めてしまうんです
もしあの時僕が中学校の先生になるって線等を得られたら僕は中学校の先生として時間
を使っていけるし
もし大学の先生を選んでいたら中学校の先生らんだ僕とは全く違う時間の中身になるん
です
人生は時間で出来てい
その人生の時間をめいいっぱい有意義に次回知りたい
そのためには
a か b かという二択に出会ったらその両方をできている c 案を見つけて
それに時間を使えている人生のほうが
充実してると思うんです
この時間の意識が弱いと
第三を見つけるってアイディアがわかってたとしても
選びやすい2択の方に流されてしまう
時間は無限にはありません
限りある人生の時間を何に使うのか
その選択はとても大事な選択なんです
二つ目は想像力です
僕はあのシーンを考えようとしたわけじゃなくて
あるアイディアを思いついてそれが後付で
a も b も取れるしーあんだったって気づきました
でも普通は逆です
a か p かって言いたくに出会ってから想像しなければならない
まだ
具体性がない第三を見つけて
行動に移すためには
a も b も両方やれている自分
それに時間を使えているその人生の時間をそれに仕えている自分を想像するということ
が大事なんです
第3話咲かそうとするんじゃなくて想像しようとするって事が大事なんです
3つ目は
強い動機です
僕は最後に満足したあって人生を終えたいってずっと思ってました
その強い動機があったからこそ地位やを思いついた時に
実際に構造に
鬱だし実践し続けることができたんだと思います
人生の時間をより良いものにしたいっていう強い動機
それこそが
2頭をいる可能性を模索して実践するための原動力になるんです
皆さんそれぞれの中にある
人生の時間をより良いものにしたいというその動機を大事にすること
それこそがこのアイディアを実践するうえで最も重要なことだって思うんです
さあこれからにた国であったらそしてその二択は
どちらも捨て方へ3択だったら
その両方を取れるようなあなただけの第三を見つけて下さい
そしてその財産を見つけることができたならぜひそれを実戦へと繋げてみてください
[拍手]